>>E'RE BACK WITHR. DEBORAH
BIRX, WHITE HOUSCORONAVIRU
TASK FORCE COORDINATOR DURING
THTRUSK ADMINISTRATION, HAS A
NEW BOOK.
YOUR BOOK DETAILS THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION'S COVID RESPONSE
IN THE EARLY STAGES OF THE
PANDEMIC.
YOU'RE QUITE CRITICAL OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND OTHERS IN
THE ADMINISTRATION.
YOU WRITE, SOME ROAMING THE
HALLS OF THE WEST WING BELIEVE
THE LISS WE DID, THE LESS WE
WOULD BE ACCOUNT FRBL WHATEVER
WAS ABOUT TO HAPPEN.
TAKE US INSIDE THOSE HALLS.
YOU SAY EARLY ON THE PRESIDENT
WAS RECEPTIVE TO YOUR
RECOMMENDATIONS BUT THAT ALL
SEEMED TO CHANGE IN EARLY APRIL.
WHY?
>> SO WE HAD DONE THAT LARGE
ANALYSIS AND THAT PROJECTION TO
SHOW IN THAT FIRST SURGE BETWEEN
100,000 AND 240,000 AMERICANS,
EVEN IF WE WERE VERY GOOD AND
PERFECT, AND WE REALLY MITIGATED
AGGRESSIVELY LIKE WE WERE DOING
ACROSS THE COUNTRY, WE WOULD
LOSE THAT MANY AMERICANS IN THAT
FIRST SURGE.
THERE WAS A GROUP IN THE WHITE
HOUSE THAT TOOK THE SAME DATA I
WAS USING, USED A DIFFERENT CASE
FATALITY RATE.
YOU HAVE TO KNOW DATA, AND OUR
DATA WAS SO DELAYED IN THE
UNITED STATES FOR REPORTING,
THAT YOU COULDN'T USE OUR DATA.
BUT THEY USED OUR DATA.
I USED EUROPEAN DATA BECAUSE THE
COLLEAGUES IN EUROPE HAD BEEN SO
GOOD ABOUT SENDING ME THEIR
DATA.
I'M SO GRATEFUL TO THEM, AND SO
MY PROJECTIONS WERE BASED ON AN
ACCURATE CASE FATALITY.
THE CEA GROUP, OUR COUNCIL OF
ECONOMIC ADVISERS, DID A SEPERAL
ANALYSIS AND CAME UP WITH AN
ANSWER OF 26,000.
I'M SAYING 100,000 AND MORE.
THEY'RE SAYING 26,000.
THAT NUMBER RESONATED WITH MANY
BECAUSE IT WAS SIMILAR TO A
NORMAL FLU SEASON.
AND IN THAT MOMENT, I THINK THE
PRESIDENT FELT THAT I HAD
BETRAYED HIM AND MADE UP THE
NUMBERS AND THAT WE WOULD NEVER
GET TO THE 100,000 THAT HE HAD
RESOLVED IN THE 30 DAYS TO SLOW
THE SPREAD.
>> ONE OF THE MOST MEMORABLE
MOMENTS IN YOUR TIME IN THE
WHITE HOUSE WAS OF COURSE WHEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP SUGGESTED THAT
INGESTING CHEMICAL DISINFECTANTS
TO TREAT COVID AND OF COURSE
YOUR REACTION TO THAT.
LET'S TAKE A LITTLE STROLL BACK
ON MEMORY LANE HERE.
>> AND THEN I SEE THE
DISINFECTANT WHERE IT KNOCKS IT
OUT IN A MINUTE.
ONE MINUTE.
AND IS THERE A WAY WE CAN DO
SOMETHING LIKE THAT BY INJECTION
INSIDE OR ALMOST A CLEANING?
>> SO IN THE BOOK, YOU SAY THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S COMMENTS MADE
YOU FURIOUS.
IT BLEW UP THE CREDIBILITY OF
THE TASK FORCE.
I HAVE TO SAY, WHEN I ASKED YOU
ABOUT THE PRESIDENT'S COMMENTS A
FEW DAYS LATER IN A TIME WHEN
POISON CONTROL CENTERS WERE
WARNING PEOPLE NOT TO INGEST
DISINFECTANTS, THIS WAS YOUR
RESPONSE.
>> I THINK IT BOTHERS ME THIS IS
STILL IN THE NEWS CYCLE.
I WORRY THAT WE DON'T GET THE
INFORMATION TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE THAT THEY NEED WHEN WE
CONTINUE TO BRING UP SOMETHING
THAT WAS FROM THURSDAY NIGHT.
>> SO IT BOTHERED YOU IT WAS
STILL IN THE NEWS CYCLE.
DO YOU REGRET NOT TAKING THAT
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE THE
CORRECT INFORMATION TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ABOUT WHY THEY
SHOULD NOT INGEST BLEACH INSTEAD
OF CHASTIING THE NEWS MEDIA?
>> I DID IMMEDIATELY OBVIOUSLY
GO TO THE PRESIDENTIAL ADVISERS
AND OTHERS IN THE WHITE HOUSE TO
MAKE IT CLEAR THAT THOSE WERE
NOT THERAPIES AND THE VERY NEXT
DAY THE PRESIDENT SAID THEY
WEREN'T THERAPIES, HE WAS
JOKING.
CDC PUT UP AND FDA PUT UP THESE
WERE NOT TREATMENTS UNDER ANY
CIRCUMSTANCES.
I WAS SO WORRIED ABOUT BOSTON
AND DETROIT AND CHICAGO Y WANTED
TO USE MY VERY FEW MINUTES
TALKING ABOUT HOW TO PREVENT
THIS VIRAL SPREAD AND HOW TO
SAVE AMERICAN LIVES.
AND I WAS JUST SO FOCUSED, JAKE,
ON THE DATA AND TRYING TO GET
THE RIGHT INFORMATION OUT THERE
WHEN THERE WAS SO MUCH SWIRL OF
INFORMATION.
I WAS JUST FOCUSED ON THOSE
ELEMENTS AND THAT'S WHY I SAID
THOSE THINGS.
AND I'M NOT AS POLISHED.
I LEARNED A LOT IN THE WHITE
HOUSE.
I'M JUST NOT AS POLISHED AS MANY
OTHERS WERE.
I LEARNED QUICKLY, AND I TRIED
TO NOT MAKE THE SAME MISTAKE
TWICE, BUT YOU POINT OUT A VERY
IMPORTANT PIECE.
AND I WAS JUST SO FOCUSED ON
WHAT WE NEEDED TO CONVEY THAT
DAY.
>> YEAH, YOU NOTE THAT PRESIDENT
TRUMP CAME OUT AND SAID THAT HE
HAD BEEN JOKING, BUT YOU WRITE,
THE MEDIA AND THE PUBLIC SAW
THROUGH THIS.
>> YES.
>> HE WASN'T JOKING.
WE ALL REPORTED IT.
AND WE ALL NOTED HE WASN'T
JOKING.
YOU SAY AFTER THE DISINFECTANT
DEBACLE, THINGS FUNDAMENTALLY
CHANGED FOR THE TASK FORCE AND
THAT YOU WERE INCREASINGLY
SIDELINED AS THE MONTHS WENT ON.
YOU WRITE, THOUGH THE PRESIDENT
DIDN'T UTTER THE CATCH PHRASE
YOU'RE FIRED, I FELL LIKE I HAD
BEEN.
YOU CONSIDERED QUITTING AT ONE
POINT.
WHY DID YOU DECIDE TO STAY?
>> THERE WAS NO ONE ELSE IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
TONY AND BOB AND STEVE HAHN WERE
IN THEIR RESPECTIVE AGENCIES AND
WORKING AS HARD AS THEY POSSIBLY
COULD, AND THAT'S ALSO WHAT I
WANTED TO SHOW, HOW PEOPLE WERE
WORKING TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
SOMEONE HAD TO BE THERE TO
CONSTANTLY GET THE INFORMATION
OUT, THE CORRECT DATA, WHAT
NEEDED TO BE DONE.
AND THAT WAS THE THING I
ALWAYS -- THAT WAS THE KIND OF
SCHIZOPHRENIC NATURE OF THE
WHITE HOUSE.
AT ONE POINT, THE PRESIDENT IS
SAYING THIS.
AND I'M FUNDING, AND HE'S
WRITING DEFENSE PRODUCTION TO DO
THIS.
AND SO AS LONG AS WE WERE ABLE
TO MOVE THE BALL CLOSER AND
CLOSER TO THE GOALPOST, I FELT
IT WAS VALUABLE FOR ME TO STAY.
>> YOU'RE CRITICAL OF THE CDC IN
THE BOOK.
YOU WRITE, QUOTE, IN MANY WAYS,
ANTI-TRUMP SENTIMENT HAS
PREVENTED PEOPLE FROM SEEING THE
FULL SPECTRUM OF THE BREAKDOWN
AT THE CDC IN THE PANDEMIC'S
EARLY MONTHS.
THAT CONTINUES TODAY, UNQUOTE.
WHAT KINDS OF FAILURES ARE YOU
TALKING ABOUT FROM THE CDC?
>> I THINK THE NUMBER ONE PIECE
IS ACCESS TO REALTIME DATA.
THEY HAD YEARS TO PREPARE FOR A
PANDEMIC.
THEY HAD DECIDED THAT THEIR
PREPARATION WAS GOING TO BE
LOOKING FOR SYMPTOMS RATHER THAN
DEFINITIVE LABORATORY DIAGNOSIS.
I COME OUT OF A LABORATORY AND
CLINICAL BACKGROUND, AND IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO ME TO KNOW
WHAT THE PATIENT HAS, NOT WHAT I
THINK HE COULD HAVE BASED ON
SYMPTOMS.
WE HAD SPENT TWO DECADES MAKING
SURE THAT EVERYBODY IN AFRICA
THAT HAD THE FEVER WAS DIAGNOSED
WITH EITHER HIV, TB, OR MALARIA.
DIDN'T MATTER WHERE YOU LIVED,
HOW FAR DOWN THE ROAD.
HERE IN THE UNITED STATES, WE'RE
DECIDING IF PEOPLE HAVE FLU OR
NOT BY SYMPTOMS.
SO IT WAS HOW THE PANDEMIC
PREPAREDNESS MOVED FORWARD IN
THE UNITED STATES THAT WERE
THOSE ORIGINAL SINS.